die letzten wochen und monate haben uns
gezeigt wie wichtig eine starke miliz
ist als wir gemeinsam im mai die erste
teil mobilmachung durchgeführt haben
sind 3400 waren für den einsatz
vorbereitet worden und in folge dann in
den einsatz geschickt worden und es sind
auch jetzt noch herziger die hälfte
dieser soldatinnen und soldaten im
einsatz
diese frauen und männer der miliz
beschützen und schützen unsere
botschaften und unsere grenzen
sie unterstützen die sicherheitsbehörden
und die gesundheitsbehörden wir haben
viele dieser einsatz räume auch besucht
und der tenor der jeweiligen
behördenvertreter unter exekutive der
war einstimmig
ohne die männer und frauen der miliz
wäre keiner dieser einsätze möglich
gewesen
und ja es ist nicht alles zu 100 prozent
rund gelaufen denn so ist das nun einmal
wenn man etwas zum ersten mal macht
daher haben wir uns dazu entschieden
dass das gerade diesen einsatz vor allem
auch zu lernen hieß das dass wir ihn so
gut wie möglich evaluieren müsst dazu
haben wir unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten im einsatz gefragt wir haben
die kommandanten der kompanie zu uns ins
haus zu einem runden tisch zusammen
geholt und ich habe in den einzelnen
räumen vor allem auch eines gemacht ich
habe zugehört
die anliegen der soldaten die warnung
sind zahlreich das beginnt bei der
bezahlung wo es zu ungleichheiten durch
dass er das gebührengesetz kommt das aus
den 50er jahren stammt in diesem
zusammenhang werden wir eine
regierungsvorlage zur harmonisierung
ausarbeiten die dann im herbst im
parlament zur abstimmung übergeben wird
eine so glaube ich ist aber auch wichtig
klarzustellen weil es viel zu wenig
bekannt ist in der öffentlichkeit und
deshalb durchaus unterschiedliche
berichterstattungen auch gegeben dazu
alle militzer soldatinnen soldaten
bekommen im einsatz ihr ziviles geheilt
von uns weiter bezahlt dass bis zu einer
obergrenze von 9695 0 56 cent jan da
kommen dann noch einige zulagen dazu mit
denen wir uns inhaltlich beschäftigen
müssen
sie sehen also das märchen vom soldaten
im einsatz wie weniger bekommt das im
zivilen leben das ist jedenfalls ein
märchen
was haben wir noch gehört und gelernt
etliche interessensvertreter der miliz
sind auch mit ausbildungs anliegen auf
nicht auf uns zugekommen
wir haben gesehen dass der größte
veränderungsbedarf in der ausbildung von
chargen zum unteroffizier besteht denn
das ist aktuell nur dann möglich wenn
man sich für 13 monate durchgehend in
eine ausbildung begibt das werden wir
ändern denn in wahrheit ist das ein
bereich der die idee der miliz die
grundidee konterkariert
denn wenn jemand mehr an verantwortung
übernehmen will
indem er unteroffizier werden möchte so
müssen wir das auch ermöglichen wir
müssen die ermöglicht sein und wir
arbeiten daher an einer modularisierten
form der unteroffizier unter
offiziersausbildung die dann auch mit
dem jeweiligen zivilen berufsleben
vereinbar ist was noch angesprochen
worden ist insbesondere auch beim runden
tisch mit den kommandanten der
aufgebotenen kompanien das war der akute
mangel sicherheitswesten für die
pistolen ich habe das nicht nur bei
diesem bunten tisch gehört sondern auch
immer wieder in den einsatz fahren
selber wir haben dann umgehend und das
war wirklich ein beschaffungsvorgang der
sich sehr schnell gegangen ist
2820 neue sicherheitspolster erworben
die jetzt bereits im umlauf sind
immer wieder ist auch angesprochen
worden ein mobilitätsproblem im
minusbereich und das ist auch der grund
warum wir 200 neue immer in lkws für die
miliz geschafft haben auch diese sind
bereits im zulauf ja nun stehen wir vor
einem weiteren großen bedarf an
ausrüstung und ins heute frei machen
soll
damit wären wir mannes ausrüstung
schutzausrüstung fahrzeuge und waffen
dieses problem oder diese große
herausforderung an investitionsstaus das
gibt es nicht erst seit der ausbildung
aufbietung der miliz sondern das ist ja
hier im ressort und auch darüber hinaus
seit vielen jahren bekannt und es ist
viele jahre auch versucht worden ein
paket unterlegt auch mit finanziellen
mitteln für die miliz zu schnüren
ja nun ist es unser der miliz
beauftragten general mehr
hannes eder und der mithilfe der
mitarbeiter das war sowas gelungen ein
200 millionen euro schweres paket für
die miliz auszuhandeln
dieses miliz paket konnte so unserem
regel budget hinzu sie wissen wir dass
das regel budget unseres ressorts das
höchste ist dass wir jemals hatten mit
254 5 milliarden euro eine steigerung im
vergleich zum vorjahr um 258 mio
prozent genau also dieses budget von 200
millionen euro kommt zum regel budget
dazu und wird dann in drei tranchen
nächstes jahr und übernächstes jahr
ausbezahlt werden
was ist das wichtigste insbesondere für
unsere soldaten was wird damit beschafft
werden
wir werden 26 millionen euro in neue
funktionsfahrzeuge investieren unter
anderem den pinzgau ersetzen
wir werden 88 millionen verwenden und
tarnanzüge kampf helme schutzwesten und
nachsicht brillen anzuschaffen
wir werden 22 millionen in führungs
mittel investieren was meine ich damit
hält sechs gruppen funkgeräte die kathi
systeme haben wir werden auch 16
millionen in die modernisierung der
gewehre stg 77 investieren und in neue
scharfschützengewehren beschafft werden
eine notwendigkeit ist es auch in
lagerräume und garagen für den blitz zu
investieren dazu werden wir 28 millionen
das zusatz beschiss benötigen und ein
weiterer bereich
das ist generell der betrieb der miliz
das sind dann die weiteren 20 millionen
war mir ist es an dieser stelle wichtig
zu betonen dass unser bundesheer aus dem
lied besteht und aus dem beruf sehr
genau diese beiden teile bilden zusammen
unser heer unser österreichisches
bundesheer wenn nur einer dieser beiden
teile geschäft ist so ist das auch das
bundesheer
daher ist unsere marschrichtung ja und
ich freue mich heute wirklich sehr
dass wir gemeinsam was ich gemeinsam mit
dem blitz beauftragten wiesen
etappensieg verkünden darf dankeschön
sehr verehrte frau bundesministerin
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
frau bundesministerin für mich ist das
eine große wertschätzung dass ich heute
hier mit dabei sein darf wenn du ein
sonderinvestitionsprogramm 200 millionen
für die miliz der öffentlichkeit
vorstellt wie sie alle wissen die
aufbietung der einsatz der miliz ist
noch nicht zu ende
die kanone hat die korona krise hat uns
noch immer in den bann und wir werden
sehen wie die entwicklung weitergeht
aber eines zeigt sich und es war
goldrichtig aus heutiger sicht ein
mutiger schritt erstmals in der zweiten
republik die lead in teilen aufzubieten
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten aus dem
militär seit anfang mai in corona
einsatz in unterschiedlichen bereichen
und ich konnte mich bei meinen
zahlreichen truppenbesuchen davon auch
selbst überzeugen dass es eine äußerst
positive rückmeldungen aus der
bevölkerung gibt und für mich mindestens
so wichtig auch dass es seitens der
exekutive der polizei großes lob gibt
für die qualitativ sehr hochstehende
professionelle zusammenarbeit mit
unseren milizsoldaten ich weiß dass
unsere milizsoldaten höchst
professionell disziplin hier mit
überzeugung und auch mit leidenschaft
diesen einsatz absolvieren
und daher möchte ich mich sehr herzlich
bei allen milizsoldaten bedanken die in
diesen einsatz gegangen sind und
teilweise noch im einsatz stehen
ich möchte mich aber auch bei ihnen
unternehmern und arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgebern bedanken die diesen einsatz
auch unterstützen und seine miliz
soldaten haben während dieses einsatzes
eindrucksvoll gezeigt österreich kann
sich auf die miliz verlassen die miliz
ist eine wesentliche und unverzichtbare
säule des österreichischen bundesheeres
und bei der analyse der bisherigen
einsätze unserer miliz wurde aber auch
dank schonungslos aufgezeigt und auch
bestätigt dass es einen gewaltigen
nachholbedarf von großen
investitionsbedarf gibt bisher verfügen
unsere milizverbände der strukturierten
miliz über keine materielle
vollausstattung und das ist ein
nüchterner gefunden und als miliz
beauftragt da habe ich mich jetzt
wirklich jahre lang intensiv bemüht
einen entsprechenden sonde invest mit
der österreichischen bundesregierung zu
verhandeln und jetzt ist es soweit und
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar ich freue
mich für unsere milizsoldaten und
milizsoldaten aber natürlich auch
persönlich
diese investitionen sind unabdingbare
voraussetzung dafür dass teile der miliz
also die bürgerinnen und bürger in
uniform die anspruchsvollen und
komplexen aufgaben die mit dem blick in
die zukunft jahr nicht weniger werden
sondern aus heutiger sicht vermehrt
auftreten werden auf hohem
professionellen niveau bewältigt werden
kann und das neue paket zielt darauf ab
den selbstschutz der milizsoldaten
deutlich
zu erhöhen und es geht auch darum den
modernen anforderungen des militärischen
aufgabenspektrums durch moderne und
damit auch notwendige ausrüstung zu
entsprechen mit diesem im westen könne
circa 50 prozent der selbstständig
strukturierten lilith mit zeitgemäßer
ausstattung und ausrüstung ausgestattet
werden es geht insbesondere auf die frau
bundesminister hat schon in zahlen
ausgeführt es geht um die persönliche
schutzausrüstung das hat sich gerade
jetzt auch bei diesem einsatz als
besonders wichtig und als besonderes
bedürfnis heraus gestellt
es geht um die verbesserung an 80
fähigkeit verbesserung der
kommunikationsfähigkeit und mobilität
und ich darf an dieser stelle auch die
aktuelle situation unserer miliz
bataillone dastehen
derzeit sind von den zehn strukturierten
miliz mathe lernen das heißt in jedem
bundesland gibt es eines in wien gibt es
zwei bataillone sind nur drei bataillone
entsprechend ausgestattet und mit den
investitionen die die frau
bundesminister jetzt angekündigt hat
werden damit weitere vier bataillone
volk ausgestattet werden können das
heißt dass damit auch in zukunft der
holt disposition zur wand geht auch im
zuge dieses einsatzes gemacht werden
musste dass dieser deutlich weniger
werden wird und sie sehen dieses paket
bringt eine erste wirklich relevante
verbesserung und damit eine deutliche
steigerung der einsatzfähigkeit von
teilen unserer militär
dadurch können sowohl die aufgaben bei
den katastropheneinsätzen
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz
entsetzen und auch bei allfälligen
einsätzen im rahmen von kooperationen
rasch und deutlich effektiver
durchgeführt werden
und als vertreter der wirtschaft
eigentlich noch eines dieses miliz paket
repräsentiert eine sehr hohe
österreichische wertschöpfung
das heißt das ist auch damit eine
investition in unternehmungen aus der
österreichischen wirtschaft
durchschnittlich beträgt die
österreichische wertschöpfung 70 prozent
und die neuausrichtung unserer miliz
umfasst nicht nur bereits die
angesprochenen investitionen in höhe von
200 millionen euro
und besonders eben die deutliche
verbesserung damit auch der mobilität es
wird einen weiteren wichtigen
stellschrauben gedreht um die situation
unserer miliz soldatinnen und soldaten
deutlich zu verbessern
es geht um die novelle des herrn g
jahresgebühr gesetzes dort wird eine
harmonisierung bei den besoldungs
unterschieden eine deutliche angleichung
verbesserung gebracht werden
es geht auch um in logistik paket zur
vermeidung von
sozialversicherungsrechtlichen nach
denen die milizsoldaten teilweise bis
jetzt haben und es wurde auch schon
angesprochen eine veränderung und damit
deutliche verbesserungen bei der
ausbildung für die ausbildung zum milito
visier
es muss wieder eine modulare ausbildung
eingeführt werden an sonst kann das von
der wirtschaft und von den arbeitgebern
nicht wirklich unterstützt und getragen
werden und dass auch die übungs
tätigkeit deutlich noch einmal erhöht
werden soll auch das ist ein richtiger
schritt den einsatzfähigkeit und
einsatzbereitschaft bedeutet auch dass
man im vorfeld entsprechend regelmäßig
geübt hat und ich halte diese drei
punkte die ich jetzt auch angesprochen
habe sehr sehr wichtig dafür dass unser
milizsystem noch einmal deutlich
zukunftsfit und auch attraktiver gemacht
wird ich selbst werde nicht müde werden
mich für die ausstattung und
wertschätzung der mili zeit zu setzen
weil es sicherheit schlicht und einfach
nicht zum nulltarif gibt und ein
spätestens seit dem ausbruch der kroner
krise ist ein klar dass die miliz eine
ganz wesentliche säule für die
sicherheit unserer unseres landes ist
und es braucht daher entsprechende
ressourcen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
geist festzuhalten dieses miliz paket
deckt noch bewerten nicht den bedarf
unserer gesamten miliz aber für alle
milizsoldaten ist das ein relevanter
erster und sichtbarer erfolg das heißt
wir sind in die richtige richtung
unterwegs weitere schritte müssen folgen
und in diesem sinne bin ich der frau
bundesministerin und auch der gesamten
österreichischen bundesregierung sehr
dankbar zum bekenntnis einer gestärkten
miliz und damit auch einem gestärkten
österreichischen bundesheer fehlt an